♪ ♪
>> Greg: ON "SNL," PETE
DAVIDSON APOLOGIZED TO
CONGRESSMAN ELECT DAN CRENSHAW
FOR MOCKING HIS WAR WOUND.
>> I MADE A JOKE ABOUT
LIEUTENANT COMMANDER DAN
CRENSHAW.
ON BEHALF OF THE SHOW AND
MYSELF, I APOLOGIZE.
IT WAS A POOR CHOICE OF WORDS.
THE MAN IS A WAR HERO AND HE
DESERVES ALL THE RESPECT IN THE
WORLD.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHAT DAVIDSON
HAD SAID INITIALLY ABOUT
CRENSHAW.
>> YOU MAY BE SURPRISED TO HEAR
HE'S A CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE
FROM TEXAS AND NOT A HIT MAN AND
A PORNO MOVIE.
I KNOW HE LOST HIS EYE IN WAR OR
WHATEVER.
>> Greg: REMEMBER CRENSHAW
HADN'T DEMANDED AN APOLOGY.
HE TAPPED THE BRAKES ON THE
ALWAYS REVVING OUTRAGE MACHINE.
>> I WANT TO GET AWAY FROM THIS
CULTURE WILL BE DEMAND APOLOGY
EVERY TIME SOMEONE MISSED
SPEAKS.
THAT WOULD BE HEALTHY FOR OUR
NATION TO GO IN THAT DIRECTION.
WE DON'T NEED TO BE OUTWARDLY
OUTRAGED.
I DON'T NEED TO DEMAND
APOLOGIES.
>> Greg: BUT "SNL" KNEW WHAT
IT HAD TO DO TO QUELL A P.R.
NIGHTMARE.
MAN UP.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE YOU SAYING THAT.
>> ARE WE GOOD?
>> WE ARE GOOD.
APOLOGY ACCEPTED.
♪ ♪
>> ARIANA GRANDE.
>> THIS IS PETE DAVIDSON.
HE LOOKS LIKE IF THE METH FROM
BREAKING BAD WAS A PERSON.
>> Greg: FACE-TO-FACE, SO RARE
THESE DAYS WHEN WE HIDE BEHIND
FIREWALLS AND LAWYERS.
"SNL" GAVE CRENSHAW THIS SPACE
TO SPEAK AT LENGTH ABOUT
VETERANS AND UNITY.
>> AMERICANS CAN FORGIVE ONE
ANOTHER.
WE CAN REMEMBER WHAT BRINGS US
TOGETHER AS A COUNTRY AND STILL
SEE THE GOOD IN EACH OTHER.
THIS IS VETERANS DAY WEEKEND.
WHICH MEANS IT'S A GOOD TIME FOR
EVERY AMERICAN TO CONNECT WITH A
VETERAN.
TELL A VETERAN "NEVER FORGET."
WHEN YOU SAY NEVER FORGET TO A
VETERAN, YOU ARE IMPLYING THAT
AS AN AMERICAN, YOU ARE IN IT
WITH THEM.
NEVER FORGET THOSE WE LOST ON
9/11, HEROES LIKE PETE'S FATHER.
I WILL SAY PETE, NEVER FORGET.
>> NEVER FORGET.
>> Greg: THAT IS LEGITIMATELY
AWESOME.
THERE WERE THREE WINNERS,
CRENSHAW FOR HIS RESPONSE TO A
CARELESS COMMENT, "SNL" FOR
FINDING A CLEVER WAY TO CLEAN UP
A MESS AND AMERICA WERE BEING
HANDED AN HONEST TO GOD'S
BLUEPRINT FOR DEALING WITH
FUTURE OUTRAGES.
INSTEAD OF RAMPING UP THE RAGE,
IT DIALED BACK.
WE'VE SET UP BEFORE IT'S BEYOND
TIME TO STOP CHASING SCALPS,
DEMANDING APOLOGIES AND THEN
REFUSING THEM.
HAVEN'T WE HAD ENOUGH OF THE MO
MOB?
I KNOW I HAVE.
TO HEAR CRENSHAW INITIATED A NEW
WAY FORWARD, EXPRESS YOUR
OPINION, DON'T CONDEMN, AND SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
"SNL" RESPONDED WITH HUMBLE,
GOOD HUMOR.
IT'S ALL GOOD AND DARE I SAY
HUMAN.
FINALLY A SKIT WORTH REPEATING.
I THOUGHT, DANA, PERFECTLY
EXECUTED ON BOTH SIDES.
>> Dana: AND THEY KEPT IT A
SECRET SO EVERYONE WAS
SURPRISED.
THAT HELPED.
I FIND DAN CRENSHAW QUITE
REFRESHING.
I REMEMBER WHEN HE WAS IN A NINE
PERSON PRIMARY.
THERE WAS AN OPEN SEAT IN
HOUSTON AND HE WAS TRYING TO GET
ATTENTION.
THERE WAS A WOMAN RUNNING ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
SHE WAS VERY, VERY WEALTHY AND
SPENDING ALL SORTS OF MONEY.
HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY MONEY TO RUN,
SO AND WHAT HE DECIDED TO DO WAS
RUN HIS DISTRICT, 25 MILES OVER
FOUR DAYS AND TRY TO GET
ATTENTION.
I THINK WHAT'S HAPPENED IS
HOUSTON HAS FOUND ITSELF A GREAT
NEW LEADER.
THEY HAVE THIS CONGRESSMAN.
POP CULTURE, IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE NICE TO HIM FOREVER.
TAKE THIS MOMENT.
IT WAS A REALLY GOOD LESSON
ABOUT LEADERSHIP.
I ALSO APPRECIATED THE
SUGGESTION FOR WHAT TO SAY TO A
SOLDIER.
RATHER THAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE, TO SAY NEVER FORGET.
I LIKE THIS.
>> Greg: I THINK THIS NEEDS TO
BE REPOSTED EVERY TIME THERE'S A
NEW OUTRAGE.
THIS IS KIND OF HOW YOU SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
>> Juan: YEAH, TO ME, IT WAS
SO CLASSIC AND SO GOOD.
I CAN'T GET OVER CRENSHAW.
>> Nicole: YOU ARE AGREEING
WITH GREG.
>> Juan: IT'S NOT OFTEN BUT IT
DOES HAPPEN.
I THOUGHT DAN CRENSHAW WAS SUPER
CLASSY.
I THOUGHT HE WAS CLASSY FROM THE
START.
I THOUGHT WHEN HE SAID I DON'T
NEED AN APOLOGY.
PEOPLE SAY SILLY STUFF ALL THE
TIME.
I THINK IT WAS REALLY, YOU KNOW,
ABOVE AND BEYOND FOR HIM TO
ACTUALLY COME TO NEW YORK AND GO
ON THE SHOW AND GO THROUGH THE
WHOLE THING.
I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS TERRIFIC.
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME ABOUT
CRENSHAW IS HE'S NOT YOUR
PROTOTYPICAL POLITICIAN.
HE'S A GUY WHO WAS A REPUBLICAN
BUT HE'S BEEN HIGHLY CRITICAL OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP, FOR EXAMPLE.
IT STRIKES ME THAT WE NEED MORE
PEOPLE LIKE THIS IN PUBLIC
OFFICE.
>> Greg: A VETERAN ESPECIALLY.
>> Juan: ESPECIALLY ON
VETERANS DAY.
I THINK THERE'S A CLASS OF 12 OR
SOMETHING VETERANS COMING IN
THIS TIME.
SEEING MORE VETERANS AND MORE
FEMALE VETERANS AND I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
IN FACT, THERE'S A PAC THAT
PROMOTES VETERANS RUNNING.
VETERANS KNOW EACH OTHER IN
MOMENTS OF REAL THREAT AS
AMERICANS.
>> Greg: IN REALITY.
>> Dana: THEY DON'T CARE IF
THEY ARE REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT.
>> Lawrence: IT WAS A GREAT
MOMENT.
SOMETHING THAT COUNTRY CAN
EMBRACE.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS NECESSARY,
PERSONALLY.
I THINK SO OFTEN PEOPLE ON THE
WRITER ON ON THE RECEIVING END
OF THIS AND THE TONE NORMALLY IS
TO FIRE THAT PERSON, GET RID OF
IT OR GO THAT PERSON.
YOU SAY ONE THING AND IT
DESTROYS YOUR CAREER.
I DON'T WANT TO GET ON CONSTANT
APOLOGY TOURS.
I'VE SEEN IT ON COLLEGE CAMPUSE
CAMPUSES.
THE MOB IT WILL TAKE OVER
SOMETHING SO SIMPLE THAT
COULD'VE BEEN HANDLED BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
GOOD GESTURE, VERY POLITE, COOL
TO SEE.
I'M JUST NOT BIG ON THE
CELEBRATION OF IT.
>> Greg: YOU THINK IT'S MORE
OF AN ISOLATED INCIDENT.
>> Lawrence: QUITE FRANKLY IT
WAS FOREST.
IT WAS FORCED.
THE EXECUTIVES CALLED HIM IN AND
SAID YOU HAVE TICKED OFF THE
VETERANS.
YOU'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING TO
MAKE IT RIGHT.
IF IT WASN'T ABOUT THAT, THEY
WOULD'VE DONE IT BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS.
>> Dana: IT WAS ON THE
TELEPROMPTER.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT WAS A SLIP OF
THE TONGUE.
>> Nicole: I LOVE THE WAY WHEN
I'M SEEING FROM CONGRESSMAN
ELECT DAN CRENSHAW.
I THINK IT'S GREAT THAT HE WENT
ON "SNL" AND HAD A LITTLE OLD
FUN WITH IT.
SHOWS HIS PERSONALITY.
SHOWS WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO.
I THINK PETE'S DAVIDSON APOLOGY
WAS MEDIOCRE AT BEST.
I WISH WE DIDN'T GET TO THE
POINT WHERE THERE WAS AN
APOLOGY.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE NEEDED ONE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THE COMMENT CAME
OUT OF HIS MOUTH.
HIS FATHER DIED ON 9/11 WHEN HE
WAS A YOUNG BOY AND DAN CRENSHAW
LOST HIS EYE HIS THIRD COMBAT
TOUR.
HE'S GOING TO MOCK HIM FOR THAT?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
THOUGHT PROCESSES.
IT WAS NOT OFF THE CUFF.
IT WAS A WRITTEN STATEMENT.
I CAN'T WRAP MY HEAD OR ON THE
FACT THAT THEY THOUGHT IT WAS
OKAY.
>> Greg: I WILL GO BACK TO MY
DEFENSE, EVEN THOUGH I SAID IT
WAS A LOUSY JOKE.
FOR SOME TYPES OF HUMOR, THE
HUMOR IS IN THE FACT THAT IT'S
AWFUL, THAT YOU'RE SAYING
SOMETHING SO OBJECTIONABLE IT
CAN'T BE REAL.
>> Nicole: IF IT CAME FROM
ANYPLACE OTHER THAN "SNL" WHO
MAKES A MOCKERY OF REPUBLICANS
EVERY WEEK, MAYBE I WOULD SEE A
LITTLE BIT OF HUMOR IN IT AS
LONG AS DAN CRENSHAW DID AS WELL